uh welcome to alex alex is one of the
um
leaders in this computational
statistical gaps uh
uh project that's been going on in our
field for a couple of years um he's one
of the fellow fellows fellows here this
semester so he's here to tell us about
optimal spectral recovery
subspace take it away outlets
uh great okay so thanks a lot this is
going to work with sang well at georgia
tech
um so here is the problem i'd like to
talk about today
uh recover a structured vector planted
in a random d dimensional subspace
um okay so i give you a random subspace
except that there is one particular
vector hidden in it
um the subspace imagine has dimension
uh d much smaller than n so n is the
ambient dimension and we're given a
d dimensional subspace inside
that and the this hidden vector in the
subspace that we're trying to find has
some kind of special structure that
distinguishes it from all the other
random looking vectors
um a primary example being sparsity so
uh let's imagine maybe a vector has only
row fraction of entries non-zero
and those non-zeros will just basically
be plus minus ones except uh normalized
so we'll use the normalization
okay
so um you know the motivation for this
is that it's sort of a generic task in
machine learning related to various
other problems but uh i will not spend
too much time on this
let me instead tell you kind of a
uh precise statistical model for this
problem
so the thing we're going to observe is
called y it'll be some basis times a
rotation
so what does it mean
uh the thing we observe is going to be
an n by d matrix and we're going to
think of the columns as being the basis
for the subspace we are being given
and the way we generate it is like this
we first just find some basis for our
subspace
and the way we do that is take this
secret planted vector v and sort of just
put it there as the first column
fill the rest in with a bunch of random
gaussians
okay so certainly the column the columns
of this uh you know span the subspace
we're interested in but then we
multiply by a random orthogonal matrix
to sort of uh do a change of basis
uh this ch this uh change of basis does
not change the column span so it doesn't
affect the actual subspace but it makes
it so that v is not just sitting here as
the first
vector in plane view
instead we get some sort of random
looking basis for our subspace
is that okay
a slightly harder variant turns out i
could just give you some arbitrary basis
for the column span of b instead of this
particular sort of random looking one
um it turns out to not really make a
difference that with a bunch of
technical work whenever we're able to
solve this one we can also solve the
slightly harder version and so i won't
really get into the difference
okay
so let me tell you a bit about firework
for simplicity i'll think about this
particular scaling regime so we kind of
have two parameters one is the sparsity
of the planted vector
and the other one is the dimension the
dimension of the small subspace um
within the ambient space
and so we can think about the parameter
space as being sort of this square
and there are uh
you know a bunch of prior work on this
problem so here i'm specifically
restricting to the case where the
planted vector is like a sparse throttle
marker
so first of all information
theoretically it's possible everywhere
in the whole square
by some kind of brute force search if
you kind of try all the sparse vectors
you'll eventually find it
but i want to talk about polynomial time
algorithms and so there's a bunch of
prior work on this
showing that certain
areas here are easy so starting with dna
hand
then some non-convex optimization sum of
squares a faster spectral method
okay so so this is what the phases
diagram kind of looks like before our
work
and we sort of settle the rest of it
so
we show that
in some sense this blue line is kind of
the real uh barrier between
easy and hard
so we have an algorithm in this whole
green region the dotted uh you know the
striped line is sort of new and we also
have some kind of evidence based on low
degree polynomials for hardness in the
remaining region
and so
this is uh probably the most
technical slide of the talk so get ready
[Music]
one of the key
insights you know it's fairly simple but
was
quite important especially for the lower
bound was to realize that this problem i
told you about can actually be reframed
as a totally equivalent
other problem that looks maybe quite a
bit different
so just to recap this first
p1 is the problem i told you already
right we think about these columns as
being the span of uh spanning our
subspace and we generate it in this way
um and a couple new things i'm going to
call mu just the entry-wise distribution
of the planted vector so you can imagine
it's some kind of sparse thing
and we're going to imagine r is a random
orthogonal matrix
now let me tell you about the other
problem which turns out to be the same
so we're now going to really think about
the rows of y instead of the columns
um and what these rows are going to be
they're basically going to be you can
think of them as iid samples from a
certain distribution and what's the
certain distribution well first we pick
some random unit vector in d dimensions
this is just going to be the same for
all of our samples
and then each of our samples y i
sort of has distribution mu in one thick
in that fixed direction u
but in all other directions it's kind of
just gaussian
right so a sample y i if i if i look in
direction u project into that sort of
secret direction i see the distribution
mu whatever it may be
but anywhere else any other direction
just looks gaussian
or any orthogonal direction let's
gaussian another way to write this a bit
more formally is like this that uh you
know y i is so
v i
is the distributed like mu so this is
kind of the special part in the u
direction
and then this is saying gaussian in all
other directions except for you
okay
any questions about these two
problems
okay so why are they the same i claim
that
these literally give you the same
distribution over matrices y
um
where you know this this mu here
corresponds to the same mu here the
entry-wise distribution of v
and so
okay why is that
uh right so you know i've suggestively
written vi here because it does indeed
correspond to the
the same v
now the less clear part is like what
does this u correspond to
so u turns out to correspond to the
first row of the random rotation
and why is that
well this row kind of tells you um
you know what how where the secret
hidden coordinate gets rotated to
and it turns out the rest of the rows
don't really matter because this stuff
is all just gaussian and so it doesn't
matter how you rotate it it's all kind
of rotationally invariant anyway
in some sense the problem that goes by
the name non-gaussian components
analysis
um
that's entirely possible okay i'm not
sure if i've heard this name but uh i
think we're gonna hear about it tomorrow
so maybe we can figure it out
yeah it's totally very related to uh
yeah aaron's talk
or maybe a few talks um yeah by taking
you to be this parallel banking
distribution that's exactly that as well
good
okay so
is anyone uh convinced these
distributions are the same
so
one way to see it is to kind of look at
this picture
and just imagine doing this matrix
multiplication and you know what is each
row going to look like
and the claim is that it's going to look
like this
if i just kind of imagine uh
you know doing the matrix multiplication
i have to
add up these
rows with these coefficients
and so i get vi times u
right that's the first part here
the rest of these are
orthonormal
basis for everything except the u
direction
which gives you this part
okay
so
let me tell you a bit about the results
so there is this very nice algorithm so
we did not invent it it comes from
hopkins tramshee sawyer so sam and seal
are here in the room um
so
the algorithm is to take the leading
eigenvector of a certain matrix so
remember the y i's are the rows of this
observed matrix yeah
previous thing so are these models um
equivalent to
the one where you would take you know
where you would model the
complement by subtracting out the
direction
and thinking more samples
that style of thing where like you know
are you talking like a like the negative
which type of thing
where i give you a basis i see yeah
there's some question is is should i
give you a basis for the subspace or
should i give you a basis for the
orthogonal complement of the subspace
i'm not sure
i mean they're equivalent for polynomial
time algorithm of course
not clear that they're equivalent for
like low degree algorithms or something
i think
is that the question yeah or i don't
know just for kind of technical reasons
it might be easier but
yeah like here i'm imagining d being a
lot smaller than n so the orthogonal
complement one gets a bit weird because
i'm giving you like
an almost full dimensional
subspace and you're supposed to you know
take a very small subspace that i didn't
give you
but yeah
good okay
so what is the algorithm
um it's some kind of special method so
you build some weird matrix um and you
take its leading eigenvector and you
hope that this leading eigenvector will
be close to u
um
this is the same algorithm from hss
except for this extra normalization term
which is not so important
and once we have you it turns out you
can get
the
in a very simple way
you know i won't try to explain maybe
why this particular thing but you know
maybe it makes sense that uh
if you think of these y's as i id
samples that you're summing over your
samples of something
and okay something it turns out to be a
particular degree for polynomial
um so what are our main results for sort
of the upper bounds
so hss already studied this and
through kind of this condition and we
with some extra work kind of
improved it to this uh optimal condition
or condition we think is optimal
some other technical improvements are
that we have guarantees in l infinity
norm instead of l2 which implies that
you can actually exactly recover the
vector v instead of just estimate it in
two norm
uh this is probably maybe the most
technical part of the proof is this
leave one out analysis but i won't try
to get into that
another thing that's new is that we can
also cover sort of this dense case where
rho is actually equal to one this is
just a plus or minus uh one vector
so a planted rademacher vector in a
subspace uh similar to aaron's talk
and so here
you know there's a spectral method
succeeding when d is smaller than n and
we think it's hard
i don't exactly remember what was in our
paper but like probably was the constant
sparsity kind of regime
like like a one-tenth non-zeros or
something i guess and you're saying that
uh
like completely dense is just as is like
just as easy
yeah that's right it doesn't
it's the same algorithm
so there's a yeah there's kind of a
choice which is you have to look at the
bottom eigenvector now instead of the
top which i'll tell you why in a second
but yeah basically the same algorithm
still works
the intuit
yeah so here's roughly why this
algorithm works at a very high level
you can start by saying what's the
expectation of this
right this uh this matrix want to
analyze turns out to be a nice rank one
thing
um in the direction u right so that's
gonna help us have a top eigenvector
close to u
but then there's this term this kind of
signal-to-noise ratio
is the four norm of the hidden vector
minus 3n and 3n is the four norm of like
a random gaussian vector
so somehow this term is measuring you
know how much does the four norm of r
vector differ from that of a random
vector
so if this thing is sort of big either
positive or negative that's going to be
good for us right it'll either give us a
big positive eigenvalue or a big
negative one
you know then the rest so all kinds of
technical work is hidden here but the
rest is to
balance sort of the spectral norm of the
remaining part and say that it's not too
big
and in the end you get some condition
that just uh you know looked a bit
complicated but depends on sort of the
four norm of the vector and so on like
this
um and so for example in this sparse
rademacher case
um you know this is the conditions for
the algorithms to succeed this is the
what i wrote before
but then there's also this other thing
that the sparsity row should be bounded
away from one third
why is this
varsity one-third happens to be the
point where the four-norm of a sparse
vector exactly coincides with that of a
gaussian vector
so this algorithm would not work in that
well the second norm won't tell you
anything because
um
we've normalized things to make that the
case
same as like the third norm if your
thing is distributed symmetric the form
normal is kind of the first
degree where you hope to gain something
and so that's what this algorithm is
using
um but you know the positive if uh if
say
your vector matches maybe the second
ends fourth
moments of the gaussian maybe there's
some higher order six degree spectral
method that also works i don't know what
this looks like but uh
yeah potentially there's some other
algorithms that would display this yeah
well i'm just wondering about
a quiet planting where i match the first
t moments of the gaussian
with my distribution and try to make it
harder
yeah um
right yeah you could certainly
do that i mean we have yeah i think we
have ways to at least predict what's how
hard it should be using this low degree
stuff which i'll get to in a second
in a sense that is parallel difference
yeah repair so the parallel techniques
hard example is in the in the
non-gaussian direction making a discrete
distribution which matches as many
moments of gaussian as you can
um
great so that's it for sort of the
upper bounds side
let me
talk about the lower bounds now
so
if we want to convince ourselves this
problem is hard what do we do
well the first thing to note is that it
would be sufficient to talk about
hardness of a certain detection problem
so um
you know if you want to say that it's
hard to recover the planted vector we
can instead think about trying to show
that it's hard to just distinguish these
two things so this is the same exact
distribution from before
this is what we call planted and then
we're going to compare that to null
distribution where just the whole basis
is i had a gaussian with no
special planted vector okay
and the goal is now that i give you a
sample i give you this matrix y that
comes from one of the two distributions
and you just have to tell me which one
it was
um it turns out you can show that if
this detection problem is indeed hard
then this implies that it's also hard to
recover the vector v hopefully this is
quite intuitive and can be
formalized by a polytime reduction
but i won't get into this
and so you know how are we going to
argue that this problem is sort of hard
well remember that this was some
spectral method that succeeded in the
easy regime
right what does it look like it's some
deep id matrix where each entry is a
particular d degree 4 polynomial in the
entries of y
right kind of two degrees coming from
here and two from here
and so we know that in the easy regime
you can solve the distinguishing problem
just by sort of thresholding the biggest
uh eigenvalue in absolute value of this
matrix
this follows from the
analysis
before
and so we might wonder maybe there is a
better spectral method right why did i
pick this particular polynomial i could
pick different polynomials maybe of
degree 6 or 8 or something
higher
but we some in some sense show that this
won't help you at least for this uh
sparse rademacher
distribution on the vector
but actually any polynomial size
spectral method with constant degree
whose entries are constant degree
polynomials
is not going to succeed
in sort of this conjectured hard machine
okay here's a bit of a more formal
statement of this if you're feeling
ambitious
but uh essentially this is saying in the
easy regime there is some matrix where
you can kind of threshold the spectral
norm in order to tell these two
distributions apart with with very high
probability
right spectral norm is like above
twice something in one case and below
just one times something in the other
case
whereas in the hard regime
um you know any poly size
spectral method and no matter what
threshold you try to pick
you're not going to be able to separate
the two cases even by sort of a one plus
epsilon versus
one
ratio
um the main sort of weakness in this
result
is right here is that we're only ruling
out spectral methods that have a fairly
high probability of success
um you know the actual thing that
succeeds in the easy regime has a way
better probability
but you know it would be ideal to
improve this to say just little of one
or something
so i think that's a nice open problem
that's not really specific to this
planted vector but it's something
present in all of these types of loading
um okay so together these things sort of
say that this thing really is the
fundamental
um
you know threshold for when spectral
methods can succeed
okay so as maybe i've alluded to and
some of you can guess how are we going
to prove spectral methods
fail it's going to be using low degree
polynomials
so the two steps to show spectral
methods fail
first kind of show any spectral method
can be implemented as a low degree
polynomial
specifically if you take your matrix
raise it to a big power and take the
trace
um this is kind of approximates the
biggest eigenvalue
uh he turns out to need like logarithmic
degree this exponent needs to be like
logarithmic for this to work
whereas on the other hand
we're going to prove that any low-degree
polynomial
in the hard regime cannot succeed at
detection in the sense of this kind of
low-degree likelihood ratio which has
appeared
this week in a few previous talks
kind of saying no low-degree polynomial
can have a large expectation in the
one distribution while having kind of
small fluctuations in the other
and like we've heard a lot this week
this kind of falls into a long work a
line of work on low degree uh lower
bounds you know starting from many
people in the room
and for all sorts of different uh
average case statistical problems it's
kind of been shown that low degree
polynomials are actually as powerful as
the best known
algorithms for these things
and so this framework kind of provides a
unified explanation for why
these things are hard
okay here is one last
uh kind of technical lemma that
gets a little bit into the proof so if
you remember this uh planted
this sort of general setup
that i talked about where you have these
id samples
that have a specific direction a
specific distribution one direction and
gaussian everywhere else
and i'll make it even a bit more general
by saying that the planted direction
itself can be drawn from whatever prior
you like
um
here's sort of the key
you know technical step in the
in the proof is to is to actually give a
an equation for this
advantage so this thing is called
advantage here is uh just uh you know
how much can low degree polynomials
how well can they distinguish this ratio
from before
and it turns out this for this general
type of problem there is kind of this
nice closed form solution for what it
looks like and it kind of decouples
nicely into two parts
this one just depends on the planted
direction u so this is like two
independent copies of u
and that has to do with their
correlation
whereas this is something that has to do
with the planted distribution itself mu
and these h's are hermet polynomials
so these these hermit expectations would
be zero if your distribution mu or
gaussian
this is some in some sense measuring how
non-gaussian is that pointed
distribution
um
okay
and
[Music]
so um you know once one has this formula
you can sort of
plug it in for
any type of problem you have of this
form and uh
um okay so we're about out of time so
just to summarize we talked about the
planted sparse vector in a subspace
there was this reformulation of it into
a different problem
and we improved the analysis of this
existing spectral method
um
you know succeeding under some
conditions or more generally just uh you
know leveraging the difference between
the four norm of our vector and the
gaussian
and then we have sort of this matching
lower bound saying no spectral method
can do better
um
so one open problem here which i stole
from guy actually is whether we can do
reductions
uh thanks that's all
[Applause]
questions
i'm guessing that this
might have come up from some of these
sos kind of considerations so is there
also a way to think about it from like
that
yeah i don't know
any way to come up with it like that
that's a good question
have a better answer
it doesn't respond to a natural sum of
squares
did you start to recover the sk model
for
like varsity one
and like dimension of the sub space
going to zero like delta n
because it's like a boolean vector
planted in a very small dimensional
subspace in which case it's like that
max second space of your random goe
matrix
yeah yeah